صدق المجلس الامني الوزاري الاسرائيلي
المصغر للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه على فرض
سلسله من العقوبات على السلطه الفلسطينيه
بسبب توجهها لمحكمه العدل الدوليه الاسبوع
الماضي ومن بين هذه العقوبات خصم نحو 39
مليون دولار من عائدات الضرائب المستحقه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه وتحويلها لعائلته
اسرائيليين اصيبوا في عمليات نفذها فلسطين
كما تشملوها الاجراءات الاسرائيليه تجميد
البناء للفلسطينيين فيما تعرف بالمناطق
جيم بالضفه الغربيه وكذلك اتخذ اجراءات
ضدها او ضد الجهات والمنظمات في الضفه
الغربيه التي تروج لاي نشاط قضائيا او
سياسيا ضد اسرائيل
هذا وقال امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين الشيخ ان
الاجراءات العقابيه التي اعلنت عنها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وفي مقدمتها قرصنه
عائدات الضرائب المستحقه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه لن تثني القياده الفلسطينيه عن
ملاحقه حكومه الاحتلال في المؤسسات
والمحافل الدوليه وفتح سياساتها ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني وفق تعبير وطالب الشيخ في بيان
المجتمع الدوليه باجبار الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على الافراج عن ملايين
الدولارات التي تمت قرصنتها
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه بدورها دانت القراره
الاسرائيلي واكدت في بيان ان اجراءات
الاحتلال لم تثنيها الشعب الفلسطينيه
وقيادتها عن مواصله الحركه السياسي
والقانوني لانهاء الاحتلال في المقابل
اتهم وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي ليكون
السلطه الفلسطينيه بتجاهل تحسين اوضاع
الفلسطينيين وبانها تعمل فقط من اجل
الاضرار باسرائيل وفي تغريده على تويتر
الناس سلسله الاجراءات التي صادق عليها
المجلس العلمي المصغر هدفها التاكيد على
ان السلطه الفلسطينيه ستدفع ثمنا باهظا
لاي محاوله لالحاق الاذى باسرائيل في
المحافل الدوليه
معنى الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري ومعنى ذلك من رام الله مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري يبدا معك وليد
ضعنا في صوره هذه الاجراءات الانتقاميه
كما سمتها اسرائيل والتي ستتخذها بحق
السلطه الفلسطينيه
السابقه كانت قد قرصنه واستولت وسرقه مئات
الملايين من الدولارات من المستحقه
الفلسطينيين والاجراءات الانتقاميه الاخرى
التي يهددون بها بهدف بتدفيع السلطه
الفلسطينيه ما يسمونه الثمن على ذهابها
الى محكمه العدل الدوليه وغيرها
لمحاكمه اسرائيل انما تاتي جميعها في اطار
لابد من قراءته على النحو التالي الاشاره
الى ان اسرائيل في الانتخابات الاخيره
انتقلت من حكم اليمين اللي رجماتي الى حكم
اليمين الى العقائد الايديولوجي وهي بذلك
انتقلت من مرحله اداره الصراع مع
الفلسطينيين الى مرحله حسم الصراع بقرارها
مع الفلسطينيين اذا ما يقومون به الان هو
مؤشر يحمل جزر بانهم مقبلون في قادم
الايام على انت وضع مناطق مثل المنطقه وهي
تساوي 62% من الضفه الغربيه تحت السيطره
الاسرائيليه الكامله السياده بمعنى ضمها
ولذلك يمنعون البناء الفلسطيني فيها من
جديد وهذا يعني قدم 62% وضمها الى اسرائيل
وهم ايضا يريدون وقد اعلن وزراء من
الصهيونيه الدينيه وغيرهم وهؤلاء عندما
يتحدثون يعبرون ايضا بما يجيش في صدر
نتنياه واخرين بانهم يريدون تصفيه السلطه
الفلسطينيه بوصفها انها تجسد الوطني
الفلسطينيه وهم لا يريد
الفلسطيني الوطني في هذه البلاد من هنا
لابد من قراءه ما يجري على انهم مقدمات
لتصعيد كبير ويبدو انهم استمدوا المزيد من
الشجاعه من الفيتو الامريكي الذي وعدهم به
الامريكيون في المجلس الامن اذا ما تم طرح
المشاريع التي كانت تطرح لادانتهم على همم
اقتحام الرسمي للمسجد
اول الاعتداع على المقابر المسيحيه في
القدس هذه الاجراءات الانتقاميه هي في صلب
همم اجندات وجدول احزاب الاعتراف الحاكم
وتحديدا الصهيونيه الدينيه وقطاع واسع من
حزب الكود ولذلك يريدون البدء بتنفيذها
لانها تخدم اجنداتهم والمساله صحيح انهم
قلقون من الحراك الدولي للسلطه الفلسطينيه
سواء في مجلس الامن او التوجه الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه او ملاحقه اسرائيل في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لكنه في نفس
الوقت هم يريدون التقدم نحو ان يصلوا الى
مرحله يعلنون فيها انهم حسموا اسرعوا مع
الفلسطينيين بعد ان كانوا على مدار اكثر
من 25 عاما يعملون على ادارته وفق ما يخدم
المصالح الاسرائيليه هذا الاجتماع الذي
كان بالامس للطاقه من وزاره الامن المصغر
كان قد ركز لان هذا
الطابق مع الاجنده السياسيه لهذه الاحزاب
كافه وهو ايضا ما يخدم مصلحه اليمين
الايديولوجي والعقائد الذي يعتمد الهلخا
او الشريعه اليهوديه من اجل التعامل مع
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه وفي الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
كافه لان لديهم هدف واضح وهو حددته مراكز
الابحاث التي تقوم بعمليه التعبئه
الايدلوجيه وايضا التخطيط السياسي
والتنظيم السياسي لهذه الاحزاب خاصه
الصهيونيه الدينيه للمشكله من ثلاثه
تنظيمات همم عقائديه متشدده
وخطيره للغايه والهدف في من كل ذلك هو
محاوله التقدم نحو في نهايه المطاف حسن
اسرع بما يخدم المصلحه الايديولوجيه
الاسرائيليه خاصه المتطرفه
في الفلسطيني في المقابل كيف تقرا مثل هذه
الاجراءات العقبيه التي همم كما تحدث وليد
الان وقال بانها همم تقرا كمشرات على
تصعيد كبير تستمد قوتها من الفيتو
الامريكي
بالفعل هذا ما اكدت عليه ايضا الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه في بيان هو الاحدث الصدر قبل
قليل على لسان الناطق باسمها نبيل ابو
ردينه الذي قال بان حكومه الاحتلال تسعى
لتصعيد وجر المنطقه الى حافه
الانفجار وطالبه تحديدا الاداره الامريكيه
بالتحرك العاجل وايضا الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
رات بان ما يحدث وما سيحدث خلال قادم
الايام يندر بما هو اسوا واصعب لكن ايضا
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وعلى اللسان
رئيسها امين سرها عفوا حسين الشيخ اكدت كل
البيانات ان كل الاجراءات الانتقاميه
الاسرائيليه لن تثني الفلسطينيين قياده
وشعبا عن مواصله النظام السياسي
والدبلوماسي والق في كافه المحافل الدوليه
لمحاسبه اسرائيل فقط هنا نذكر همم ايمان
همم باما هو الاحدث انه الاسبوع الماضي
نجحت فلسطين في الامم المتحده بالحصول على
قرار حاسب وقاطع تم تحويله الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه قرار عمل على اعداده
الفلسطينيون من خبراء قانونيين الدوليين
وفلسطينيين على مدار خمس سنوات بالسؤال
على جواب واحد ما هي الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على الارض بمعنى تحويل كلمه الاحتلال الى
الاستعمار وهذا معناها قرا اسرائيل ايضا
بانه هناك الان تم نجاح هذه الخطوه في
محكمه العدل الدوليه همم تغيير كامل ووجوب
تغيير السياسات الدوليه اتجاه اسرائيل
باعتبارها دوله استعمار وليس فقط كدوله
تحت دوله استعمار معناها تغيير في ال همم
الصادرات الواردات همم الامور الامور
السياسيه التمثيليه الدبلوماسيه القانونيه
الدوليه وبالتالي من هنا بدات التمديدات
الاسرائيليه حتى وصف احد المسؤولين ومن
بينهم سفير اسرائيل في الامم المتحده
الرئيس الفلسطيني شخصيا بانه يمارس
الارهاب الدبلوماسي حسب وصفه اذا اسرائيل
تحاول ليس فقط ان تلعب مجموعات فلسطينيه
بالارهاب الان تصف القياده الفلسطينيه
بشخصها بممارسه منتصفه بالارهاب
الدبلوماسي اذا ردود فعل همم متواصله
ممدده ترفض وتؤكد على انها ستواصل للي عمل
الدبلوماسي والقانوني باضافه بالطبع الى
العمل الشعبي على همم المسانده في انهاء
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مراسله الجزيره وولي العمري مدير مكتب
الجزيره معنا من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لكم